so russell i want to talk to you about
your spirituality and your religion in a
second i
think what's what's fascinating about
sort of your personal story is
first of all it's just the story of
ecclesiastes essentially i mean you
basically took the solomonic journey
through
what if i had a thousand wives and a
thousand horses and
and then it seems that you sort of came
around to the view that there was
there's a certain emptiness to that but
for for somebody like me so i grew up
religious right i grew up
from the time i was a young teen like 11
12 13 years old
uh going to an orthodox synagogue very
steeped in the in these sort of
judeo-christian notions of personal
virtue and
and controlling appetites and all that
sort of stuff there there's always a
draw in
in our culture toward as you say the
fulfillment of those appetites and as
somebody who
i mean you really want whole hog on a
lot of this stuff maybe you can talk
about
you know when was it that you sort of
started to feel like maybe this isn't
the bl end all maybe maybe there's
something more than this
personally for me it took the
i it required that the encounters be
kind of lived through
i understood things theoretically and
spiritually
long before i was able to embody them
and live by them
i reckon it was it's quite hard to
monitor
how you feel if you're being
lauded and applauded if you're
successful financially and being
celebrated
it sometimes you can lose touch with
what's actually happening to you
spiritually or you know if you're not a
religious person
emotionally or psychically but i suppose
in retrospect and
i'm certainly aware and at the time i
had an inkling that i was feeling a
little disconnected
and because i'm so privileged to have
this background in addiction and more
importantly in recovery
i began to recognize that any
external stimulant that begins to govern
my state
my perception govern my moods my the way
i identify with myself
could potentially be categorized as
addiction if my life becomes about how
other people see me
about what's written about me how uh uh
how financially successful i am then i'm
kind of
living in an external object and what i
was able to well started to awaken to
because
i wasn't happy that i wasn't fulfilled
and i love your uh
your classical reference there ben it's
difficult though because things that
like the flesh is
satisfying drugs are fulfilling flowery
and praise are enticing
and distracting and it still takes
discipline in me still
now when i look at the world of
celebrity
and what i might classify as the world
of individualism
egocentrism i still find it kind of wow
appealing and
i'm a professional person i have
intention and ambition
i see the way that you run a media
organization and i think well this is
really sort of successful
you know and i i still am stimulated and
attracted to
versions of success but the difference
is now i understand wholeheartedly and i
fully accept
that there is nothing external that can
ever make me feel resolved fulfilled or
complete that if i'm ever to feel
um connected valued and valuable
awake and aware that i have to live a
life of meaning and purpose now you know
you're speaking about your own
background that you had a set of
traditional
values that were accessible to you and
i'm sure i did in my way i'm from like a
single parent family religion wasn't
sort of at the forefront of our sort of
cultural life i'm like church of england
that just means that's the thing you get
given
you just issued that on entry on arrival
there's no like
study exams or outfits required you know
spirituality wasn't like something i was
particularly thinking about this is
in a way mate this this dovetails
with a kind of ideological tool that's
used often in recovery from addiction
the belief that most people are craving
spiritual fulfillment in some way
purpose meaning a sense of community
togetherness fairness justice that
perhaps these values are not entirely
cultural but somehow inherent
and those of us that grow up without
them might try to synthesize those
values by becoming successful or by
becoming a heroin addict
by you know becoming a devoted athlete
or by
hanging around strip clubs we're all
looking for meaning purpose now
and for me pleasure is a kind of um
a palliative you know and what i really
need is purpose but the culture does not
promote these kind of messages the
culture
in my opinion promotes individualism
materialism
rationalism scientism if it can't be
measured then it isn't there
and for me i was a devotee of a
particular culture a culture that tells
you become successful
all the while i had these kind of
spiritual inclinations and yearnings but
i didn't know how to process them i
didn't
i wasn't really mentored until i got
clean from drugs and alcohol
and because those things are so
appealing and attractive you know
carnality
celebrity it took a it took a while it
took
being in it i'm very fortunate i feel
privileged to have had the experience
of the red carpets and the flash bulbs
and the adulation because now i
recognize
oh yeah i've been there still now though
ben i can see a picture of myself
in a situation of celebrity from 10
years ago
or whatever and think oh my god that
looks so appealing and cool
this that was must have meant something
but i remember
i remember that it is empty and for
people like most people like you know
when you hit those famous surveys that
are banded about young people who want
to be celebrities they want to be famous
they don't even care what they're famous
for they just want to be famous
you know i i wonder how my life might
have been different if i'd have
understood that purpose and meaning can
be connected with
internally and all that you acquire
externally whilst it might provide
gratification pleasure and it is not
good fun being poor i can personally
vouch for that
these things are not the solution to
spiritual problems so i totally agree
with you
i think that when it comes to what the
media have have
pushed upon us and what what society
modern society
pushes so much it's this idea that there
are all of these sort of
air sats solutions for the hole in your
heart that is left when there is the
natural inclination for spirituality and
for spiritual connection and
what i've said is that that the lack of
god has left a hole in our hearts and
we're trying to fill that with a wide
variety of things and
and for a lot of people that is
stimulants for a lot of people that is
that is sex for a lot of people
that is politics and and the
substitution of sort of political
polarization or tribal identification
for you know any sort of of spiritual
connection mission purpose
uh it's really easy to make that mistake
especially in a society that as you say
tends to measure things on on a very
data-driven level that happiness equals
this number of dollars plus this number
of lovers plus this amount of
uh this number of houses plus this many
twitter followers
and and the reality is that none of that
is a substitute for the sort of meaning
and purpose that
i mean pretty much every philosopher
since the dawn of time has been
searching for
yes and while we're in some ways
only qualified to speak about it
empirically from an individual
perspective it's clear that many of
these
values are culturally endorsed to
uh almost entirely to the point of
saturation
i feel like you know i've like i don't
get on tick-tock too regular you know as
a
user but i've looked at it and i felt
like my god the velocity
the potency now of that message the
power of it
i found it difficult enough not to look
at pornography when i was an adolescent
when it was
analog rags found in hedges and bushes
now your pocket is a portal to limitless
pixelated digital
sex ghosts available at a moment's
notice
how are you gonna evolve a sophisticated
and loving and empathetic sexuality
when bombarded with that amount of
stimulation it's sort of an
i suppose you could from a dietary
perspective
from a technological and pornographic
perspective um
chart these markers but i wonder where
they are more insidiously present in
culture
around ideas such as economics i wonder
where else
we're being hypnotized seduced and
guided by cultural messaging that is
not beneficial to individuals and is not
in tune with
even if you don't believe in creation or
divinity how we are evolved
to live so let's talk for a second about
your sort of view of spirituality so
there are a lot of folks out there who
consider themselves sort of spiritual
but not religious connected to something
deeper but
not sure exactly what or not really even
directed toward exactly what so
how did how does your spirituality
define yourself you've talked about
meaning and purpose
what would you say your sort of meaning
is where do you find meaning
well i find the rubric through which
my spirituality is lived and understood
is
unfortunately quite practical in the i
mean recovery from addiction and what
that gives you
is a set of principles and an ongoing
sort of almost cyclical system that you
can live within
the the first step in these 12 12 step
systems ben is
surrender i i don't know what to do
anymore my life has got problems in it
and i don't know how to control it the
second step
is about having hope that change is
possible for you as an individual
a lot of people fall down there you know
whether it's in terms of chemical
dependency or changing behavior
or more broadly because i can test these
messages are somewhat perennial and
could be applied anywhere in life a lot
of people think
the world cannot change human beings are
essentially you know defined by sort of
cruelty coldness selfishness or whatever
so
you know these things are designed for
the individual but i think are
socially applicable so the second step
having admitted there's a problem the
second step is believing change is
possible
the third step is coming to believe that
a power greater than yourself
can restore this the third power the
third step excuse me
is um made a decision to turn our will
and our life
over to the care of god as we understood
god now that's sort of
completely open to interpretation there
are people in 12-step groups from
a variety of religious backgrounds and
no religious background
at all for me what it means is
the set of values and systems that i
come up with in my head
are if not arbitrary somewhat as a
result of my conditioning and my
impulses and instincts which
i could do with some guidance on i've
already admitted there's a problem
i believe it's possible to change now i
get ready to accept help
each one of these steps can be really
unpacked quite deeply and applied i
think
almost universally to matters of
discontent
loss loneliness excessive attachment
unwillingness to accept
for uh that we live a finite life you
know i think they're really really
powerful tools
and what it's done to what it did for me
i always had a sense of
look i i always embraced mystery drug
addicts
usually do if you've taken psychedelic
drugs and had the kind of experiences
that they induce
if you feel the kind of despair and loss
and loneliness that a lot of addicts
feel and the kind of conditions that
becoming a drug addict introduce you to
criminality and the kind of you know
sort of cliche desperation that one
might encounter
in a sense it opens you up to the
possibility of god because nothing
for me you know i know you're like uh
you know you're a religious man and also
know that you
know theology and that you know
scripture but suffering
it like i'm not making claims to job
levels of suffering but to be
introduced to god on that level of
knowing
i am weak on my own i am weak i
need something powerful in my life me
fueled just by my ego and my petty
trivial desires i will live a petty
trivial life i need something powerful
and now i don't know if that's
applicable to anybody i'm sure many of
your viewers are religious i'm sure many
of them are atheistic i'm sure
many of them are individualistic it's
pointless even really to speculate but
for me personally i need to feel that
there is
beauty that there is love that there is
a kind of glory
and i think whether we're talking about
like sort of the success of marvel
movies and the way they introduce
archetypes and grand themes or the kind
of tensions that we feel politically
sometimes or the
epidemic or of mental health problems
and opioid addiction in your country
currently
this for me is demonstration of the the
yearning the need for real change
and in my humble opinion and god knows i
know your opinion
differs for me these problems cannot be
resolved within the limited framework of
current political discourse
we need to invite meaning and purpose
and if not more
directly god back into the conversation
of how we construct society and how we
organize systems of governance and
even exchange i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show sunday
special if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content